nous avons tous le choix
[Musique]
et chaque choix une conséquence
nous n'avons pas vaincu le ténébreux
nous l'avons libéré
[Musique]
personne ne devrait avoir autant de
pouvoir
tous ensemble nous avons affronté
l'impossible
mais à présent nous sommes séparés aux
quatre coins du monde
protéger
c'est la seule chose qui importe tu ne
peux le contrôler
tu sais tu as quelque chose de
particulier en toi
un appel au sang et remédiable je
voudrais savoir
comment réussir à garder le contrôle
l'ultime bataille approche
le monde entier va nous appartenir
[Musique]
si nos amis ont des ennuis pourquoi
devrais-je rester ici tu n'as pas la
moindre idée de leur pouvoir tu
[Musique]
ne peux l'ombre offre de nombreuses voix
ce ne sont pas toujours les femmes les
plus puissantes qui écrivent l'histoire
ce sont celles qui survivent
j'en ai plus cassé de mètres carrés de
la roue
[Applaudissements]
tu n'es pas un rayon petit
tu es l'eau qui fait tourner la roue
[Musique]